saliendo victoriosa de las primarias del
martes en wyoming harriet harman
agradeció en primer lugar a su mayor
partidario donald trump
[Aplausos]
con su apoyo inquebrantable desde el
principio nos impulsó a la victoria esta
noche wyoming ha hablado en nombre de
todos los que están preocupados porque
el juego está cada vez más amañado en su
contra reich durante su campaña heckman
hizo eco y amplificó las afirmaciones
del ex presidente sobre un presunto robo
de las elecciones presidenciales de 2020
en un estado en el que el 70% de los
votos fueron para trump en aquel
entonces heckman venció a liz cheney de
forma aplastante poniendo fin a la
candidatura de su rival para un cuarto
período en la cámara de representantes
al aceptar la derrota jeannie que había
presentado su campaña como una lucha por
el alma del partido republicano aumentó
sus críticas al ex presidente we must be
very señor debemos tener una visión muy
clara de la amenaza a la que nos
enfrentamos y de lo que se necesita para
derrotar la he dicho desde el 6 de enero
que haré lo que sea necesario para
garantizar que donald trump no vuelva a
estar cerca del despacho oval y lo digo
en serio mientras trump fue presidente
seyni voto en consecuencia sus posturas
republicanas más del 90% de las veces
pero después de los disturbios del 6 de
enero en el capitolio rompió con los
miembros del partido y se convirtió en
una de sus más firmes críticas
sentándose como vicepresidenta del panel
del congreso que investigaba el asalto